[Musique]
derniers mois parce que la montée de la lumière
Cela a été très important et cela a
fait ce que nous avons décidé
investir dans ce type d'énergie
une famille sur 50 60% serait la
normal que vous économisiez dans un
facture normale pas dans une facture de 100
euros Eh bien, si une famille paie
100 euros par mois Maintenant quand tu fais ton
installation de votre centrale photovoltaïque
Eh bien, je paierais 40 35 ou 40 45 euros
[Musique]
que nous avons donné un coup de pouce définitif à
une technologie qui coûtait très cher n'était que
un écologiste rêve de le mettre dans
le marché pour commencer
pour que cette courbe de coût descende
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est arrivé
plus de 90% par rapport aux prix
que j'avais il y a 14 ans
[Musique]
c'est que même tout au long du mois de
octobre et jusqu'à début novembre
il y a peu de temps il faisait très beau
spectaculaire et nous avons également pu
tirer le meilleur parti de l'énergie
Nous avons déjà pu générer à partir des plaques
qu'il est vraiment vrai qu'ici dans
Espagne, nous avons beaucoup plus facile à
pour amortir rapidement l'investissement
que vous faites sur l'addition ET sur le
économie